different types of omics data
and you probably already kind of know
what they are there's
genomic data transcriptomic data will
soon get into metagenomic data so
there's all kinds of ohmic data
and it represents some biological
phenomena this biological phenomena
drives processes that we call diseases
and they make all kinds of interactions
between different cells different
tissues
and different even organisms that come
from outside of our body
and a lot of the application of this
type of data has to do
with matching the right kind of data
with the right kind of analysis
and establishing the logic of how the
two correspond to each other so this
program is called omics logic because it
focuses
on the logical component of
bioinformatics now after you complete
this course which is an
introduction to bioinformatics you will
be free to decide
which direction do you want to take this
into one direction could be to apply
bioinformatics to different types of
biological problems
or another direction could be to maybe
focus
on the algorithmic component maybe you
want to design better
algorithms to find associations between
different factors
or maybe you want to adapt different
types of methods to
novel technologies in the omix world
to help process and make sense of these
types of big data sets
so this program is like a gateway for
you to then make further decisions about
what you want to do with this
information
but we also hope that in the context of
this program you will find
how different types of informatics
approaches
of data storage organization analysis
visualization
reporting can be applied to different
types of biological
examples and so what we'll do today is
we'll review
what we have covered so far and so far
we've covered
kind of an introduction to working with
data and then working with genomic data
and then
now you are completing the working with
transcriptomic data
but as you understand how these
different types of data sets
are similar or different it's great to
see the application of the different
methods of analysis
in the context of what we call projects
before we jump into that i want to
remind you that throughout this course
it was myself uh beeps
who's not mentioned here but she's been
playing an active role in helping
kind of everybody walk through the
content and find all the
different resources that are available
dr mohit mizunder
who has been primarily focused on
updating uh dr
ogi on how to manage the different types
of content that we have
um and dr preetka orr has been making
sure that all of the
assignments have been checked and you
get responses to
you know the different questions that
you have so we've all been trying to
kind of work together
to make sure that you've had so far an
experience that is beneficial and useful
to all of you
and i want to remind you that if you do
have any further questions
you can reach out to us and there are
several different ways that you can do
that
and please allow for some time for us to
have you know time to get back to you in
time
um the way that this program was
organized
just schedule wise is that we are right
now right about here in the mid
assessment
and this mid-assessment is going to
uh provide you with some kind of a
self-evaluation for where you
have uh gotten to in this process of
this course so we'll share
after this session is over a survey a
form that you have to fill out
that will help you kind of understand
where you are
and just to kind of review what types of
topics we have covered already
we looked at two languages that
are very actively used in the domain of
bioinformatics
and this is r and python uh so again
this course is not going to make you
necessarily proficient in either one but
it is going to give you
an overview of how different methods
could be
packaged in different packages and
libraries
so that they could easily be called as
functions and how you can write scripts
to import data visualize data and
perform different types of analyses
then we turn to genomic data which is
generated by next generation sequencing
and we looked at
a few different examples of how this
could be used for
oncology studies and different types of
pharmacogenomic examples and stuff like
that
so then we looked at what's called
transcriptomic data and so
transcriptomic data
is different from genomic data because
instead of dna
it's generated from rna the rna
in humans comes from the process
of transcription and translation
ultimately when the dna
is transcribed into mrna and the mrna
messenger rna
is what becomes eventually proteins
but it goes through several changes
including alternative splicing
and so when you look at the difference
between next generation sequencing of
dna data
and mrna or rna data the analysis is
also going to be different
but the same in the sense that you still
have to map
the short reads onto a reference and
that reference becomes the genome of
whatever host you are sequencing so in
the case of
the different types of applications of
methods
they're going to be universal methods
like mapping alignment
normalization etc and there are going to
be also specific methods like a method
for finding
specific variants like variant calling
for genomic data
or methods for evaluating alternative
splicing which would be more relevant to
mrna
because that goes through alternative
splicing now as you go through this
uh course on transcriptomics 1 and
transcriptomics 2
you will find that we use an example and
this example was the same paper that you
started with the pre-assessment in
which was on patient-derived xenograph
models
and this is a good project to use
because it essentially shows how
alignment or mapping of those reads to
the reference genome
can be used also as a way to study the
interaction
between the two tissues the tumor and
the micro environment so we have this
case study which is one of the examples
that we will use
throughout this course to kind of
understand the application of
bioinformatics
to a variety of different projects so
what we'll do today
is we'll take a look at some additional
projects
and we'll talk about how bioinformatics
can be used
to detect somatic mutations in cancer to
study drug resistance and tuberculosis
to understand viral adaptation and
geo-localization of the ebola virus
and look at other examples that have to
do with both biomedical
and non-biomedical topics so we'll take
a look at a few of these examples but
you also have access to a lot of
different projects that will point you
to
towards the end of this session so how
do all of these program resources fit
together
so what we hope to create in the
omixlogic program
is a way for someone who is completely
new to bioinformatics to understand
how different methods essentially help
someone that has to deal with large
quantities of data
that ultimately have a biological
interpretation
using a number of different resources
that you are likely to find
in any kind of a bioinformatics lab so
these include
some training materials that are all
based on projects
and research publications because a
large component of bioinformatics is
being able to
take data from somebody else right so
when you are
a bioinformatician when you learn
bioinformatics and then you apply it to
a data set
more likely than not that data is going
to be owned by somebody else which means
that somebody else
generated in a specific way has the
metadata
that you probably either don't have or
need help
understanding and so we hope that
through this process
you actually learn how to read research
publications
and specifically the methods portion of
the research publications where
the type of data is described how it was
prepared
what does it represent and therefore you
can plan your analysis
the second part is the platform and it's
a big data platform
because many of the data sets that
you'll end up using
have thousands of samples across many
conditions
with hundreds of thousands of
observations per individual sample
and because of that in any lab you will
have access to some kind of a server
some kind of a centralized location that
has all the necessary scripts
and maybe some loaded data sets and
instead of having everything on your
computer you would have to separate
the design of your analysis from the
actual
uh analysis process which is conducted
somewhere else
and so this is something that you have
to get used to you
first understand what the data is and
logically have to create a pipeline and
then
execute that pipeline and find all the
necessary
outputs to answer a specific question so
hopefully
in examples like transcriptomics one you
were able to
see how the pipeline produces maybe
hundreds of individual files
and you have to know where to look to
find the specific answer to a question
that was posed to you
you also have to understand the logic
behind the analysis
so that you are running pipelines that
make sense
the third resource is coding so coding
is a big part of bioinformatics because
it helps you
modify things from how they work for
somebody else's project essentially
to how they should work for your project
and so
a lot of times people have designed
these packages
and libraries around specific
applications
for example maybe somebody designed a
specific analysis package to study
haplotype diversity of hiv viruses
in a population now you're faced with a
new challenge
it's coveted 19 and you have to apply
the same logic
but to data that is a little bit
different because for example hiv
evolutionary speaking does not change as
fast as covet 19
and it also doesn't spread as fast as
covet 19.
so while you have the similar approach
you have to
tweak some parameters modify the type of
data that you're putting in
and also maybe change the way that you
present your data visually so that it
makes sense to your collaborator so
you're not speaking about hiv anymore
you're talking about covet 19
so that's why it's important to
understand that you
are going to a lot of times work with
scripts and packages and functions that
somebody else has designed so you have
to
read the code and understand what the
code means
in some places you will have to modify
the code for example the type of input
data
and then also tweak parameters along the
way
so that the outputs from your analysis
are relevant
and also meaningful
and then finally we have this fourth
component
which are projects and so these projects
really illustrate the application
of all of these three different
components to different types of
biological or biomedical
challenges that you're likely to find
yourself
applying these methods to
so first of all on the platform the
types of
analyses that are going to be useful for
this program
include analysis of gene expression
alignment of
large whole genome sequencing data sets
like you did with the barium calling
pipeline in genomics one
analysis of phylogenetic structures for
hundreds of samples of for example code
19
genomes but also you have a lot of other
tools that could be used in this
omics kind of world because ultimately
the omics data oftentimes
represents different sides of the same
biological phenomena so if you think
about
a problem like cancer which is a systems
biology problem
it's not just the tumor as a whole
that is important for analysis you
actually have to look at
individual cells that have specific
variants
and maybe have different types of
properties affecting other cells around
them
and so the genomic variants have an
effect
on transcription those probably have an
effect on protein protein interaction
that's where you want to focus for
intervention and maybe you are designing
some kind of a molecule to
stop that interaction and so multiple
types of
omics and multiple types of approaches
are going to typically be used in the
context of the same project and that's
what the platform is built around that's
what the logic of the platform is
and so we hope that through different
examples that you
explore during this program you are able
to see
both individual methods but also how
those methods fit together to help you
study
a biological phenomena from the system's
perspective
the other resource that you probably saw
was
this application in r and python and so
ultimately popularity comes and goes
right uh in bioinformatics there are
still a lot of methods that are written
in pearl
that you know is a language that's been
around for decades
and so as you look at the different
types of
popular or not as popular applications i
think what you will find
is that they are all useful as long as
they produce the types of results that
you
can interpret and you understand how
they have been produced and so the goal
of these exercises that we are providing
is to help you learn the language
help you see how this type of analysis
is different from maybe
other types of applications of coding
like maybe
in web design or you know analysis of
other types of data
because you have to deal with data that
is maybe unique
to the world of bioinformatics for
example this kind of sequence data
even though you can find sequences in
text and
natural language processing they're very
specific because they do have only four
characters or maybe
you know 22 amino acids or something
like that so they are very
unique to the world of bioinformatics
finally the coursework that we've
discussed so far
in the course was an introduction to
bioinformatics that we hope kind of
provide you with
an overview of different applications of
bioinformatics
followed on by introductory courses in
genomics and transcriptomics
and now we will also continue to explore
what's called
machine learning and how it applies to
transcriptomic or other types of data
as well as metagenomic data which is
experiencing a tremendous growth of
applications because we see the
applications of microbiome
to anything between severity of covid19
infection to sensitivity to different
foods
to acne and different types of skin
diseases
and all kinds of other types of
applications so
we hope that through this brief overview
you'll kind of get
a little bit of a feel for what is
different about this data
and how potentially you could use this
data in your
different types of projects
so far you have done well we
hope that most of you have been able to
look through transcriptomics 1
and transcriptomics 2 courses
so i'll just briefly comment on what
these two courses
include and then you know i want to make
sure that we pause and
hear any questions that you have about
this
the transcriptomics courses are designed
to kind of reiterate on some of the
aspects of
genomic data and genomic sequencing
that you probably already read about in
introduction to genomics and genomics
one
so what's important about this is that
in the traditional sense of rna-seq
you are trying to estimate an average
of mrna expression across a whole
variety of conditions
and so several methods have been
designed to make sure that
the error in your input data is
minimal your variation from technical
noise
is addressed and then you have some kind
of signal
that could quickly summarize information
from
thousands or even tens of thousands of
points of information
into something that you can easily grasp
and so these methods that we will
discuss
help you explore your data and then
ask specific questions about the data
and by asking the question
what we mean is generating and answering
a
testing a hypothesis so to give you an
overview of rna-seq
you probably learned this already but
we'll kind of go through the steps
the logic is that first of all your
input data
is pre-processed or in other words it is
trimmed from different types of
technical variation that you do not want
to include in your analysis
the second step is mapping when you map
the data onto
a reference genome and here potentially
there could be
a number of different types of
information that you're looking for
it could be only looking for known
transcripts
transcripts that have been reported and
are put into some kind of a database or
a file called the genome transfer format
or you want to identify potentially
novel types of alternative splicing
events or transcripts
that could inform some kind of
deregulation that is typical for complex
diseases like cancer
ultimately then you want to quantify the
levels of expression
so that you understand for each
individual mrna
how much of it do i detect in a
particular sample or
a group of samples now based on the
exploration
of this table of expression of the
quantified levels of expression
you can now design a hypothesis and that
really has to do
with how do you organize your data into
meaningful groups
and then you have the methods of
differential gene expression
that you can use to study how
this hypothesis applies to individual
observations in your data so let me ask
you here
the first question when i talk about
samples and observations
what do i mean when i say observations
what are they
and you can add your answer in the chat
box
um let me just pull up the chat box here
or you can unmute yourself if you want
to answer
okay so ken is saying sequence reads
anyone else
replication of a sample says strong
[Music]
okay so when i say again i'll repeat the
question when i say
samples right those are individual
samples that i've taken for example
biopsy samples these are biological
samples
but when i say observations within a
sample
what does that mean
does anyone else have any
answers for this just maybe wait until
we have
a couple more okay so kendrick the same
trends
with a question mark trends
anyone else
so one more answer i'll move on
the data okay so all fairly good
questions
so let's start with cans answer sequence
reads
so in fact the evidence that i have is
in the sequence reads but those sequence
reads
came from some biological material and
so the biological material
represents mrna that was expressed
right so the observations that i have
are
mrna transcripts and those transcripts
typically come
from gene sequences because in the
transcript
we have exons and introns introns are
spliced out
exons are spliced together and we have
gene sequences so these are sequences of
protein
isoforms so you can refer to these as
transcripts or
isoforms and those are the observations
so when i
do the next step when i look at
differential gene expression or i test
my hypothesis
i'm actually testing that hypothesis
each time for an individual
observation or individual test
on a gene or an mrna transcript
okay tron answered replication of a
sample
so typically we do have replicates in
our data set because for any biological
process there's individuality that we
want to kind of get rid of
and so a lot of times we're looking at
replicates of 3
or even 10 or more per condition so we
can get a better sense of what's common
for that condition
and not unique for that individual but
those are not the observations that
within
each sample right those are observations
that are different samples
kendrick mentioned trends you know i
assume that this is trends in gene
expression so
yes those are kind of derivative values
that we can analyze from rna-seq data
and obviously this is the data but just
keep in mind that in
any kind of an analysis especially when
you talk about hypothesis testing you're
going to be test your hypothesis
on observations and those observations
are going to be
genes in the case of rna-seq data
so the final step is differential gene
expression and this is really where the
traditional rna-seq pipeline kind of
ends
so traditionally the pipeline is
going to be consisting out of these four
different steps
and if you master these four different
steps you can do
a lot of interesting analysis with
rna-seq data
and hopefully we'll get to a few
examples today to kind of illustrate
that
so here's another question
when would you not consider using top
hat
so first maybe let me ask
which part of this is top hat so
pre-processing mapping quantification or
differential gene expression
where in these four groups of methods
does top hat
land
okay can correct mapping
okay so but when would you
not consider using top hat thank you
so here you have four different choices
one when you do not want to
do exon detection as with non-coding rna
two when you have not run an error
correction algorithm
three when mapping on a genome that
lacks
an annotation file and four top hat
is always the best choice
and you you know you can use yeah okay
so naheed answered number three when
mapping on a genome that lacks an
annotation file so again the question is
when would you not consider using top
hat
so the answer from naheed would be when
mapping on a genome that lacks an
annotation file you would not consider
using top hat
anyone else
so i mean this is not graded so this is
just you know
for us to have a discussion about what's
right what's wrong make sure that you
understand this correctly
so feel free to guess if you don't know
okay great so everybody's guessing
number one so which is
when you do not want to do exon
detection
okay great so that is correct
it's number one because top hat
is a collection of two different types
of algorithms bow tie
and an exon detection and exon splicing
detection so a number of different steps
that help us annotate novel transcripts
based on
detection of exon splicing and then
producing what's called the
transcriptome so whenever we do
annotation of gene expression and we
quantify gene expression we can say well
everybody's got the same gene expression
everybody's genes
are expressed in a similar way so we
have a database of expressed
you know 22 000 genes we can just ask is
this one expressed yes or no
or we can say everybody's genome is
expressed differently so let us first
prepare
a transcriptome which would be a new
annotation
for this particular genome that will
tell us
which genes and which combinations of
exons are actually being expressed
and then we'll quantify all of our
samples as a
single data set so that we have
transcriptomes compared across the
samples that we have
so it is an in-depth approach an
alternative approach would be
just mapping on transcripts which would
be both tied to
t or you also have these
uh non-uh mapping
types of approaches like salmon and
callisto
that could be used without mapping onto
the genome altogether
so why would i say that differential
gene expression
is kind of like your standard into this
logic
of rna-seq expression because typically
or historically i probably should say
experiments were designed around
simple comparisons i have
one set of samples that represents
condition i have another set of samples
that represents control
and so when i want to understand a
condition i just compare it to the
control
however in as people started generating
more and more data
it started to be clear that you have a
lot more variation for example
if you have a condition like cancer you
can say here's a healthy person
and here's a person with cancer but the
healthy person is probably
you know maybe they're healthy from
cancer but they have diabetes maybe
they're
healthy from cancer or they have heart
disease right so there's
a range of things that we call healthy
and then there's also a range of
severity for a condition like cancer
maybe it's cancer stage one
two three et cetera maybe it's different
types of cancers etc
so as a result we need methods that deal
with
more variability than just grouping
everything
into these simple one or two
type comparisons and so one of the ways
that we can
do that is designing specific
regression factors that can help us
analyze relationships and so what we are
essentially saying
is that we can study the effect
of some factor that could be measured
by observing only those
genes where that effect is consistent
with the level of a factor so for
example if i have a factor of
time and i have three time points then i
can see
some trend that is only consistent with
there being three time points and say i
only want to look for genes that have
been
affected by this kind of a factor
and so here we can analyze different
types of
more complex relationships specifically
not just to spot the obvious for example
the obvious would be
there are three factors and or three
levels of
one factor called time and the
expression just goes up that's a fairly
simple type of a design that you can
spot even
without factor regression analysis but
sometimes
you have interaction of factors for
example
i have somebody who is running
and their temperature rises and somebody
who is
drinking and the temperature goes down
so when you drink
the more you drink the temperature goes
down the more you run the temperature
goes up
now i combine the two right the person
is running
and drinking at the same time what will
i find
right and so here the question would be
well how does the temperature vary
across time
and maybe i have on you know 100 people
running
and i can say well i clearly see that
when a person runs the faster or the
longer they run the temperature rises
the more they drink the temperature goes
down but when they
do it together maybe there's this
unexpected effect and so it's an
effective interaction
and that effective interaction which is
one factor in the other
having an influence together could be
unexpected for example
temperature rises two times as fast as
when a person is just running on its own
or it takes three times as long for the
temperature to rise to the same level
because the person is drinking at the
same time and so those kinds of effects
are really something that we can
investigate using factor regression
analysis
so to place all of these different
methods into
a logical kind of schematic uh
i would say that you know there are four
different specific
steps to this overall process
first of all you deal with data that
somebody has designed
so there was an experiment design
potentially in the lab
somebody said i'm going to take these
mice and do this to these mice and take
these mice and do something else to do
them and i will collect data on them and
so when you
approach a data set it's important to
understand how that data
was prepared and what considerations to
have about the experimental design
many times when that data is collected
it is provided to you
in this raw format and this raw format
just like we saw with fastq files is not
anything that you can
analyze essentially it's just short
sequences of reads
if you wanted to align them all to each
other you would fail because they come
from completely different places
of a genome and so the first
process is called data cleaning and it's
typically assumed that a
bioinformatician or a data scientist
will spend probably
between 70 and 80 percent of their time
just on cleaning and processing that
data
so when you do data processing it's
important to
understand what type of unwanted
variation
you want to eliminate so what's noise
what kind of signal
you want to preserve so how do you want
to represent the signal
in your data so let me ask you here a
question
in rna sequencing you've learned about
three methods
of quantification of mrna
does anyone remember what they are
what are the three kind of metrics that
are possible
or typically used for pair and read data
for rna-seq
okay ken is saying northern blotting
tron is saying fpkm okay so ken
northern blotting is one of the methods
to detect whether some
presence or absence of mrna maybe
quantify that but
that's not a quantification metric so
trong is correct fpkm is one of those
this is when i process
my read data and map it onto the genome
i can then
quantify the abundance of mrna
in specific metrics and fpkm is one of
them
direct count or kind of raw read count
is another one correct and so what's the
third one
does anyone else remember the third one
tpm excellent okay so fb cam
raw count and tpm so those are the three
metrics what is different between them
raw count means that i just count how
many reads i have
and so if you imagine one sample having
a coverage of
average across the genome of 1000
and another one having five again
average across the whole genome
then this metric doesn't really make
sense right because
here i just have a lot more reads so why
would i just count
from and compare them between each other
so fb cam and tpm
were designed to address this challenge
tpm
simply is transcript per million
so it says let's say you have 5 million
reads and i have 10 million reads let's
just divide it you divided by five and i
divided by ten and so that way
we will get a measurement of transcripts
that
is comparable apples to apples fpm goes
one step further and
actually also accounts for fragment per
kilobase per million which means that it
looks at the length of each individual
gene
if you have a total of 5 million or 10
million
they're not distributed equally if you
have a longer gene
that longer gene statistically speaking
is likely to have
more reads fall on that region just by
chance
and so i can also since i'm counting
transcripts or
uh you know in this case genes i can
also
incorporate this measurement of length
so that's
about processing the data there are
several considerations like we talked
about top hat right is used to detect
novel transcripts and splicing of exons
there's the levels of quantification
all of these are important measurements
to prepare my data
to accurately represent noise the
amount of signal that i have in a given
sample
and produce it in a right kind of a
metric
for the next step exploratory analysis
so can somebody give you or give me
sorry
a method of exploratory analysis that
you've learned
in the transcriptomics courses so far
just name any method that you've learned
so far
and please for all of those that are
participating you know again there are
no wrong answers here this is
just a review so if if your answer is
wrong
that's okay
okay ken is saying clustering anyone
else
does anyone else have any exploratory
analysis methods in mind
anyone else
okay well you probably remember that you
can explore
data using statistical characterization
of data properties right so what's a
property of data that we could compare
between samples
for example distribution or we can take
something like maximum or minimum value
right or we can look at skewness or we
can look at
median or mean right so these are just
different characteristics of
each individual data point you know if
we have a sample we have
some data set for that sample and we can
say okay well
is the distribution of this sample
different from the distribution of
another sample or
if i take a group of samples is the
distribution between the two
different what if the mean is different
right what if i have three samples and
the mean is low
and another three and the mean is high
what does that tell me about the
different samples
so the answer to that is that in a
controlled experiment
either that is a known factor in advance
so somebody said i'm going to take
you know cells that are living in this
rich environment with a lot of food and
you know i'm kind of expecting all of
their activity to be
up regulated okay and ken is saying they
may be from different populations yes
they are probably from two different
conditions and if i
see that i need to ask the question why
is that
and so either that could be by design so
for example two different populations
that i want to compare
they have different means that's
expected i want to compare that
or it could be noise and sometimes in
controlled experiments
you would just by chance see that one is
more contaminated than the other
or one can be a little bit uh
you know more noisy than the other and
so then you want to normalize that data
so exploratory data analysis
is not just knowing something about your
data it's asking
active questions about your data to
address those questions before you turn
them over
to what's called the actual analysis
step
so clustering is a method a method is to
characterize the data from the
standpoint of statistical properties
and that could be done using
visualization or summary statistics
and also you can use methods like
principal component analysis
that reduce dimensionality
so that we can actually make sense of
unwanted variation like
outliers or maybe groups that are too
old too much overlapping and things like
that
so once we've prepared our data and it's
ready for analysis we go
into data analysis and we already talked
about statistical model
models like differential gene expression
uh uses a statistical model
or a factor regression analysis uses a
statistical model
or we can also turn to more advanced
methods that we will learn in
transcriptomics 3
like classification and predictive
analysis and things like that and so
ultimately the end of this process
is to infer for inference right what do
we actually infer from the data how do
we interpret the results
to talk about what biological processes
are important
for this condition or how does this
biological condition compared to another
condition
so that part is very important there as
well
but at least for the process of
processing exploratory
analysis and actual comparative data
analysis
i think this is what we have covered up
until now
how does this apply to different types
of
uh problems in biomedical research
so biomedical research and we've been
kind of doing a lot with biomedical
research so far
could be divided up into three
categories basic research
and translational research and
translational research could be
in clinical or an industry application
so when we talk about basic research
imagine yourself
working in somebody's lab they
specialize in some specific topic
and they typically want to understand
the mechanism behind
some specific type of observation so
they want to understand how does this
actually work how does it happen and
typically what they want to understand
are specific principles biological
associations
methods of regulation so they're asking
questions about the basic biology
behind what is being observed and a lot
of the data sets that we have been
dealing with
they are kind of in that spectrum of
basic research
another type of an application clinical
application
means that you can actually take what
you have found from the basic level
and apply it to ask clinical questions
and clinical questions typically have to
do with either
diagnostics how do i diagnose a disease
or therapeutics how do i prescribe
treatment
and so around those two topics there's a
lot of translational research
that helps doctors be more precise
in how they diagnose and more
personalized in
how they prescribe treatments
and then there's the pharmaceutical in
the biotech industry
typically what the industry is
interested in
is some kind of a topic
that could be industrialized right and
so for example if we have
biomarkers and we can screen millions of
people
and know that for three biomarkers that
we measure
this is the drug that's going to be 24
or 36
efficient every time this is a win right
this is a
strategic advantage so i can implement
the strategy and kind of in
industrialize the process a lot of times
that has to do with the discovery
right so how can i find a drug that
solves a problem in a better way
how can i apply that drug to a certain
group of people
for patient stratification and for
biomarker driven
targeted therapy and i also can
think about how to address other types
of questions like
stimulating the system for like the
immune system for example in our body
and prepare it for some kind of an
adverse effect
so those are some applications in
biomedical research so now i'm going to
ask a question
it's not related to anything technical
this is a personal question so
feel free to answer it but i hope you're
not um
you know again this is not for grading
so feel free to answer this just for
discussion
what types of projects that you've read
about so far
in this course from introduction to
bioinformatics
to then genomics to then transcriptomics
what types of projects or what types of
applications from these three categories
are you most interested in basic
research
that would be number one two would be
clinical
or three pharmaceutical and or
biotechnology
so maybe i can see if everyone can
answer this question
so we just kind of get a survey for what
kind of interests
do you personally have
okay thank you arnold
okay so trung we actually didn't have a
four there's only three
research clinical or pharma and biotech
okay kevin pharma
kendrick and naheed clinical strong
biotech
okay jurada research and clinical
can clinical property leveraging
research studies okay
okay is that everyone let's see
we have arnold
connor trong sean
kevin naheed kendrick
joretta again
okay i think that's everything all right
great so let's talk about some of the
projects
that you could potentially think about
as you study these different methods
again remember that this whole program
is designed in such a way that we will
first
learn about different types of omics
data then we will learn about different
types of
processing and analysis of data and then
eventually we hope that by the end of
this program you will be able to
formulate
a bioinformatics project proposal so in
other words you will
propose kind of your own study if you
were free to do
whatever you want to do for the next six
months or a year what would you actually
spend the time working on
and it doesn't mean that you actually
have to work on it this is just to say
that
you know how to do it you can translate
your idea
to a data set and a method of analysis
so let's talk about that really quickly
so the types of bioinformatics research
projects that we're going to be talking
about
are called research driven by data
so these are going to be data-driven
research projects
and um beeps if you're there could you
please
post the link to making the most out of
your research projects in bioinformatics
it's just that
okay thank you so when you think about a
project
you have to consider several different
things and we already know
what you're interested in so this makes
that part of it easy
but that's the first part so these are
topics that you know and
care about and that means that can you
prepare a few slides explaining the
topic background or can you see yourself
spending a few months researching this
topic right so you have to have some
sort of motivation to move in this
direction
the second part of it is what will be
interesting to your audience so when you
consider selecting a topic you want to
think about
are there enough people that will
actually care to listen about this topic
you can test this easily by trying to
tell your parents your siblings or your
friends
about the topic that you're interested
about and hearing what they have to say
if
no one is interested to listen no one
understands what you're talking about
maybe that's too niche
it's too narrow maybe if this is only
interesting to the two friends that
always are interested in what you're
uh interested in that means that it's
not a generally kind of
interesting project and the other part
of it
is do you hear the questions or
discussion about this topic so for
example
is it covered in the media like for
example the vaccines
for coveted 19 which is a both clinical
and a biotechnology topic
have been discussed at the level of
genomic data for so long in the media
that
anybody could care and listen to that
topic but if you take a topic like
reproduction of chlamydia in uh
you know sub-saharan africa you know
maybe not as many people would be
interested in that so just think about
those topics as you select your project
idea
and then an important critical factor
that a lot of times people forget about
is that
there is a sufficient body of data
available
on this topic so this means both
publications that describe this so that
you can
base your analysis on some kind of a
reference and is there
a particular data set or typically a
number of different data sets that you
can start exploring
when you consider selecting that topic
and so in the intersection of those
things that you know and care about what
will be interesting to your audience
and sufficiently studied data available
you will find
the best and most impactful topic that
you want to focus on
and so as you move into the second phase
of this program
think about what types of data sets what
types of
project ideas and designs and analysis
methods that you feel are interesting
and potentially aligned with your
research interests could be useful for
you to focus on at the end of the
program
you will complete a research study
proposal
uh on how you can apply some of the
things that you've learned to a data set
of your own or
to one of the projects that we include
in this program
so then what's important is to make sure
that
you know the data you know
why the data was generated and you know
kind of what to do with this data
and this typically falls into these
three categories
of data sources so there could be
primary research secondary research and
tertiary research
and typically primary research is the
research that you
produce raw or original data on so this
is your first
hand observation and this is
typically where you will source your
data so that means that somebody
had a problem or a question and they
designed their hypothesis
around that or they designed their
experiment to generate data around that
problem or question
and then you will move into secondary
kind of research which is an analysis
and interpretation of somebody else's
data so that's what we
hopefully will want to do is we would
want to review
and critique and maybe improve upon
somebody else's data that they've
generated
and maybe that means adding new analysis
and maybe making novel interpretation
and then tertiary which is
kind of the next step typically we're
not going to go into that
is when you want to say okay well
everybody's interested
in this particular type of cancer let me
collect
a whole bunch of samples from this
domain and make it into an easily
searchable and curated database
and so that might include data tools and
collections
so that's not what we will do but we
will try to find
primary data sets and review some
secondary materials potentially we will
use some tertiary
research by looking into compilations
and databases to source new
data but this is important to understand
because ultimately
you want to go through sources that
describe the context
of your project and provide you with a
general background
and that means that if you think of a
topic
just think of what are the primary data
sets
what are review articles that are
available on this topic
and what are some databases that i could
search to
reference whatever i'm going to do with
this data
now from that general background you
want to move
to a more specific and focused
hypothesis
and the way you do this is you first
want to review available sources and
categorize them for example if we talk
about
different categories right we talked
about mechanistic basic research we
talked about clinical and biotech we
talked about
different types of applications and
translation of this research
you can categorize them like that is
this an article
about the basic mechanism of
transcription regulation for this
you know two genes or is this an attempt
to develop a biomarker assay that helps
me diagnose people better right so you
can categorize them into different
categories
then you want to identify gaps and
unanswered questions maybe controversy a
debate
maybe some kind of gap in
existing research so some people are
saying you know we have done this
analysis and it kind of points in this
direction but there's obviously a gap
more needs to be investigated or
somebody's saying you know i found these
three biomarkers
but they only work 50 of the time right
so what about the other 50
so you can find gaps in existing body of
research
and that will lead you to define your
question or hypothesis
so when you define your question or
hypothesis it will combine
two things the first is
what is that general background and two
what is your specific hypothesis and
that's a good place
to start writing your abstract so let's
take a look
at an abstract of a paper and see what
does this
actually tell us about why the people
selected their project
what they intended to do and what was
their conclusion
from this research article so
this is a publication
that is used in transcriptonics 3.
so if you already started
transcriptomics 3 as i saw some of you
did
you'll be more familiar with this data
set if you have not yet started
this is the link to this article
let me share this link with you
and you will find this link referenced
in transcriptomics 3 as well
ok so this article is called
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer
and as you can see the abstract is
separated here
into three sections the background
the results and the conclusions so the
background
is that first generation molecular
profiles for human breast cancers have
enabled the identification of features
that can predict therapeutic response
however
little is known about how the various
data types can best be combined
to yield optimal predictors so if you go
back to the previous slide
what is the gap or the controversy or
that specific focus
that they found in existing research
that they wanted to address in this
publication
okay does anyone have an answer just the
first sentence here
what is the background that they found a
gap
in the existing body of research and
wanted to focus on that particular gap
to answer that question
so
does anyone have
okay so sean is saying optimal
predictors okay so
how good the predictors are maybe that's
a gap right how various data types can
be best
combined to yield optimal predictions
okay so i think kevin
is identifying this correctly they are
saying that
we already know that individual features
can predict therapeutic response but
little is known about right so that's
the gap little is known about how the
various data types can be best combined
to yield optimal predictors so it is
optimal predictors
but it's in the context of data
integration so
what kind of data did they use primary
secondary or tertiary what kind of
research is this did they generate their
own data
did they take somebody else's data
how did they kind of start this study
what kind of data did they use
all right excellent so they did not
generate their own data this is not
their own data they use somebody else's
data in fact they say we used
collections of breast cancers
they used some people not only generated
the data they also
organized and collected them into a
you know searchable database potentially
right so they've used somebody else's
data
that was already organized for them so
collections of breast cancer cell lines
mirror many aspects of breast cancer
molecular patho biology
and measurements of their omic and
biological therapeutic responses are
well suited for development of
strategies to identify
the most predictive molecular feature
sets
let me ask you here what do they mean
by most predictive molecular feature
sets
what could that mean
what are we trying to predict here
okay so sean is saying antigens for
therapeutic response
anyone else
which gene expressions can predict
cancer
cell line of breast and the heat is
saying
okay so anyone else
okay the correct answer is that they are
trying to predict
drug response so you can
put drugs on cell lines see
how they respond and ask the question
what if i don't put any drug on a cell
line
can i just predict what the response
would be
knowing the molecular profiles knowing
gene expression
knowing variance could i just look at a
patient
take their molecular features and
predict what kind of a response they
will have
to a particular drug right so this is an
application
of an understanding of a basic mechanism
of let's say mrna transcription
regulation
to the ability of assigning a
therapeutic
to a particular patient now it does have
that diagnostic component as well
because i
could also identify different types of
breast cancer from doing this analysis
but
this is the project we recommend that
you start reading this publication and
kind of going through the
transcriptomics three course
to really learn about how they use the
transcriptomic data
and what kinds of methods as you can see
described right here
to do this kind of predictive analysis
and we want to make sure that you are
aware of
other types of projects that have been
designed to kind of
explain some of the analysis methods and
the data sets
and a lot of these are going to be
focused on cancer so you will see
analysis of changing immune responses in
cancer modeling cancer precision
medicine etc
and these projects are going to help you
understand an
article the methods that is used in the
article
and what types of outcomes you might
expect from the analysis
so all of these projects are essentially
done to
help you read through publications that
have been
digested by our team extracted into
types of data and types of methods so
that potentially you can develop
novel and independent projects that are
similar to these
so as you look through this project and
go through the transformatomics 3 course
and the rest of the
material that we'll do in this course
kind of use them as examples that you
can enhance
and apply your understanding of this
this analysis to whatever problem you're
interested in
so i'm gonna stop right here i think um
we do have uh mojito and beeps here that
can give you a brief
overview of your progress and kind of
where
everybody is and kind of explain
this form that we will share with you
for you to kind of give us some
evaluate your own progress but before we
do that do you have any questions about
what we covered in this session
and in fact any questions about the
material so far
just the content itself or the different
methods that you
maybe didn't understand or maybe some
question that you didn't understand that
needs to be addressed so
we didn't receive any questions ahead of
this session so we didn't really know
if you didn't have any questions but if
you do
we can answer those now so uh
mohit or beepside could you guys
take us through the progress
yes sure elia give me a moment i'll be
sharing my screen
just one moment i'm sorry i'll be
sharing
in a minute okay
so so far i've seen that uh most of you
have been very active
during this session uh so let us get
started
with the progress review here
so this is the collective review of
progress for everybody as part of the
session so we can see here
what are the different uh accounts that
you have used by accounts here i mean
the different platforms
so the pink here is representing the
codomix logic platform
the grey represents the t by info server
and the yellow is represented by the edu
platform
so this is the cumulative progress
report for everyone
in the group now let us take a look at
some of the individual progress
so before we move on to the individual
progress i see that
kendrick has been in the rank 2 on the
co dominic's logic platform so very good
work kendrick
on the code omix logic platform and he
has 11
465 points now in the upcoming
uh individual review we are not doing
uh what you are going to be seeing that
uh the points from the codements logic
is not added so you are only going to be
seeing
the edu points and the server points out
there so some of the points may not
match up
but we will be sending you the weekly
updates
soon so first we have kendrick of course
so here we can see kendrick's
profile the number of points that he has
as well as
this is the progress report from the edu
platform
that tracks the progress across uh
different time points
where you might have been active so this
just shows
the activity that you have been doing
across these
days and not actually the courses that
you have taken
so well done kendrick and as i move
through this if you have
any questions uh please let me know
excuse me so i have a question yes
please
um is it your plan to go through uh
every student's status here it's it may
not be appropriate
for uh to share everyone's status with
everybody in the class
all right so okay so we will not uh go
through everybody's progress then so
this is all that we had to share
so then i will stop sharing it okay so i
think i think if any if any
uh member of the course wishes to uh
inquire about
their present status we'll be happy to
to share that with them
sure all right okay so i will not share
this then because we had prepared
um an in-depth review of each person but
we'll not do that for today so if you
all have any questions regarding your
points or any other
related things please let me know and i
think uh
truong here had a question so was it
answered
that the course does not help us master
our code and python
yeah i can answer that so the training
in r and python includes
many aspects of basic uh
kind of you know terminology and the
different types of data
and the different types of you know
writing your own functions
and then you know there's a whole lot
that goes into i would say
proficiency in r and python what
this training will provide you with is
kind of like an
overview of some of the important
methods that you would need
if you want to use them to analyze
omics data and specifically
kind of a company accompanying some of
the
tutorials that we've had um with the
different project examples
so if you are interested in becoming
more kind of
proficient with these i think there are
some
code academy or uh data camp and you
know other types of
uh tutorials and collections of
tutorials
and you know potentially you might want
to consider spending
you know three to six months just
working on one of these languages
to become more profession proficient and
kind of professionally ready
for various coding challenges that you
might face but
with what you will get in this course i
think you'll get a taste of the
different
languages different methods and
functions that are applicable to omix
data
and the types of analyses that we do for
the projects that we've
you know selected for this course
thank you elia and uh james if you would
have something to add
further yeah uh i just want to say i i i
apologize for interrupting
that your absolutely all right that is
absolutely all right but just because of
ferpa regulations we we can't share all
that data but
i want to encourage members of the class
here uh if you have any question about
your status
or where you're course standing to
please contact uh beeps
uh personally and also i want to say uh
you know we're getting towards halfway
in in the uh
course right now and i want to encourage
you
to come forward to raise any questions
you have please don't be shy
uh there are no medals for struggling in
silence
so you know just make sure that you
voice any
concerns or challenges you have either
to the uh
faculty at pine biotech or to me and of
course i'll just pass them on to pine
biotech anyway so
uh please don't be shy and coming
forward um
so that's all i have um back to you beep
sir yeah
well i'll just uh maybe end this with um
the reflection i'm sure you can please
go ahead and i also wanted to add that
you know the forum is also open
for any question so if you are not
comfortable just
asking us you can also post it on the
forum uh so i will also share the forum
link again
please go ahead thank you so much okay
um this is the reflection it's not
really that long
but you'll see here
um you know we do ask for your valid
email address in fact just try to use
the same email address as you use
on the other platforms here and
then uh here we have just how much time
you spend
for the different courses and the
different activities uh that we've done
um and then uh here what
of the following best describes your
understanding of concepts presented in
the course
so just kind of like how do you feel
about things are you confused do you
feel confident that you understand
everything
um which of the following best describes
how prepared you feel for the concepts
and skills presented in the course
which of the following best describes
your interest in conducting future
research in bioinformatics
and which of the following describes
your interest in pursuing additional
training in bioinformatics so similar to
what
was already asked about r and python you
know is there a particular skill that
you
feel you want to now become more
proficient in
and maybe there's a particular topic
like cancer biology let's say you want
to study or maybe there's something else
that you've gotten out
of this um here we ask you to kind of
self-evaluate your skills the way you
feel
about reading and analyzing you know
different data and you know doing
different
methods of analysis that we've done here
and i've covered today
a couple of project examples but there
are more that we have
including some on tcga which is the
cancer genome atlas copenhagen
ebola virus etc or are you thinking
about more of something of your own that
we haven't covered here
so this is just to get a sense of how
you feel
about going about a project
proposal and sometimes people prefer to
work together so if you do have a
teammate in mind already
you want to work with somebody else and
develop a proposal together with
somebody else that's perfectly fine
this is something that you will have
plenty of time to work on and think
about so this isn't doesn't mean that
you have to
kind of submit a project proposal
already and
this is a bonus thing so if you do
submit a project proposal
it will be evaluated but as a bonus to
the overall training
and uh this is something that you can
answer right here um
and any other comments right so here it
says other comments that may be helpful
for assigning research project teams
if you feel like you don't want to work
with anybody else or you just want to
focus on one aspect
we ask that at minimum you try one of
the projects that we provide
the next kind of level is you want to
take one of the projects but also add on
to it by maybe doing your own literature
review
and the next stage is actually if you
want to formulate a research strategy
or how you will find and analyze
data uh you know to propose that plan
so those are some of the options that
you have so this is the form
we'll also email it to you separately
and post it on the forum so that's all i
had thank you
thank you so much elia uh so thank you
all for
attending today's session and i do hope
that
we have been able to answer any
questions that you may have
so please continue to ask any doubts
and get them cleared and i look forward
to seeing you
in the upcoming session so we will try
to schedule it at a time
which is more appropriate for everyone
to be able to join i do hope i saw that
everybody has joined in today's session
but if there is any problem in time so
we will try to
make sure that we can arrange for a
session then and this session as it is
recorded will also send everybody the
recording of this session
so thank you again and thank you james
thank you thank you thank you and thank
you elia
and dr mohick and everybody else for
attending today's session so
we will be ending today thank you okay
thanks a lot
bye-bye now